prominent black lives matter leader
hitting back at a democrat who's been
critical of the group new york city
mayor eric adams is slammed blm for
being silent on the rising violence that
impacts black americans hog newsome
co-founder of blm of new york responding
to adams while speaking to dana today
so um let's get back to eric adams this
this this mayor who spews who's a
democrat but excuse conservative and
republican talking points he's a white
man in blackface and a very conservative
minded white man he had 16 shooting
victims on the train and they say what
are you going to do about policing and
he says what about blm
is america not smart enough to see him
deflecting
the blm leader is also
taking time to defend the deep funded
police movement after reports that the
movement led to a startling spike in the
murders of black americans
the cops are not the answer answer poor
people commit crimes out of
desperation address the poverty the
republicans don't care
but they'll say we'll teach you they'll
say we'll teach you
to empower yourselves democrats want to
keep us handicapped and crippled and on
welfare
all right judge i want to go to you
first because i want to hit the actual
heart of this issue and not just how
he can be sometimes on tv as dana saw
today he says that adam's plan is a
monumental failure he says four months
into it that most of the arrests through
the plainclothes officers program are
petty crimes and what he says the d.a is
prosecuting is just violations so he
says that's a failure and that adam's
policies aren't making the city anymore
well first of all i don't know if that's
the case number one i you know i don't
know of street crime cops or the
anti-crime unit as it's been called
historically is there for pretty crimes
that's number one number two um i i
found it fascinating that we just closed
with him saying you know the republicans
they'll teach how to help what they'll
teach us and they'll try to help us but
the democrats won't do anything i mean
i'm not sure what he wants but here
here's the bottom line we can blame the
death of black americans on the black
lives matter movement to defund the
police it is that simple it there is a
statistical reality to the fact that
once that movement started with defund
police more blacks and minorities and
the inner cities were being murdered the
stats do not lie and they what shocks me
is that the people who join the movement
which i have no problem with i think the
movement is good the organization is not
but that join the movement why aren't
they saying where is our money where are
the donations you know where are the
pledges why aren't we helping black
lives and not just those those ones that
they want to highlight as as significant
and awful those involved that involve
police activists look the other way when
it comes to black lives and i i just i
don't have a lot of respect for that guy
i'm sorry you ought to be out there
fighting for all black victims and maybe
he thinks he is but as far as i'm
concerned
is adam's deflecting yeah i think he
deflects i don't think adams has done a
great job in the first hundred days i
think the first time he talked about
really making sure we get people was
when the train the guy on the train and
uh so we have a decision to make we
either keep pressuring him to protect us
or we just move on to someone else
harold one thing he did say um he says
that they believe that the mother of
poverty is or the mother of crime is
poverty so he
as he went through the interview as dana
saul
some of his talking points were a little
bit less incendiary a little bit more
careful i guess but he says that
basically the only reason there's crime
in new york city is that because there's
poverty in new york city and that police
can't be the answer
well i differ with him uh on a couple of
fronts number one i think mayor adams is
not what he described
uh number two i differ a little bit with
what the judge said about the blm being
responsible for all these things but i
do agree with your overall point judge
that
the movement is certainly something i
support more than some of the
individuals but that young fellow has a
right to to share his views he was on
the show and i i just disagree with him
i think at the end of the day my father
grew up poor group one of 15. they
didn't go out killing people and robbing
and looting they wouldn't got an
education and thank god
raise families
to say to poor people since an
indictment on poor people to say that
indictment on lower middle class and
middle-class people to say that
so i think i understand what he's trying
to say we need better policies to help
empower communities to provide jobs and
education opportunities and health care
but that's not the way you see it what
we need in this city and what other
cities need we need federal crime task
forces working with our local officials
we need more cops on the streets we need
more dollars for training police
officers so so we can avoid some of the
tragedies that we've seen in the nation
over the last year and a half or two and
finally we need to lock up people who
commit crimes
any democrat again this bell reform i
think the mayor has been
outright and against it he's been to
albany protesting and advocating against
the law i would encourage governor hokel
and others if you want to get reelected
reform bail we it was it was a benign
thing to do early on to try to figure
out how you get non-violent offenders
don't let them go to jail but a violent
offender should stay in jail period
that's what every organization who wants
to fight crime should be stating greg
this guy has appointed himself as leader
of the blm movement in new york uh is
the same guy said there will be blood on
the streets if mayor adams was elected
blm has done to black people what chris
wallace did to cnn plus
entice them with a promise and then
ditch them on the side of the road
i'm going to do this every segment so
just get used to it look um number one
yeah everything harold said is is
correct uh
and and the judge is right we have the
highest we have like the highest crime
in 30 years
we might have poverty in new york city
but we have the highest taxes in the
country so you can't blame poverty you
have to blame the corrupt liberal
leaders and when you look at these high
crime cities there's one singular
example that's there in each one
single party rule you've got to have and
this isn't a poor analogy you got to
have a mom and a dad and you got to have
a republican and you got to have a
democrat one can be more powerful than
the other but their checks and their
balances there's like you if you let
democrats run everything their very the
very worst intentions will come to light
and i'd say the same thing about
republicans they got to balance each
other out new york city has no
republican counterpoint if you look at
places like chicago or los angeles
that's missing so what happens is the
very worst ideas bubble up like the bail
reform thing was a terrible idea that
wouldn't have that wouldn't have come
through if there was a kind of a balance
between left and right you got to have
the mom and the dad politically together
to create this and also the last thing
about the crime is you know you look at
places like cnn and other media they did
champion the demoralization of the
police they they bought into it and that
fueled the first ever
national ferguson effect which is when
the when law enforcement pulls back and
that led to more crime in the crime
epidemic so you could definitely say
that the media had a large
responsibility it's not entirely blm
it's the way their message was uh was
mutated by the media dana when you guys
asked him about the six million dollar
mansion that a blm leader patrice
culler's bought and really can't answer
uh he gave really examples of what his
organization is doing here in new york
city it's much different than that well
he also was one of the
he was somebody who blew the whistle on
the fun the fundraising and how they
were spending the money and he said that
you have to be able to separate
the two yeah and i just think in the
public's mind that is difficult to do
you don't have that you're taking in all
of this information that's hard to do
now i also think that he has a good
point about something he said there's
things that he's done in his
neighborhood which is local solutions
local control that makes a lot of sense
one of them is for example they opened a
montessori school that apparently is
doing great things i said i'll come to
visit i'd love to do it but he said that
none of the media will come and cover
that story but they'll cover his other
comments well part of the reasons they
cover those comments is because they're
so incendiary exactly and unfortunate
having just in the last three weeks
interviewed mayor adams and then hawk
newsom i'm like wait if you guys got in
a room you actually agree on a lot more
for example mayor adams is saying that
like what de blasio did with the public
schools was horrible and he's trying to
reverse some of those things one of
that's something hawk newsom agrees with
um so there is an opportunity for these
two uh
leaders
one is elected one is appointed but one
is they're obviously charismatic people
that if you could just figure out a way
to get them in a room and bring someone
together uh bring them together they
might be able to achieve a lot more
incendiary by design we just did a whole
segment on it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else